[Music]
thank you
we are on the edge of Extinction we need
a lifesaver and it's in this decade that
we as politicians need to make the hard
decisions especially given our short
mandates so what are we doing just
making speeches like we're doing now
[Music]
it has never been more urgent to resume
and expand this cooperation the
challenges of our era and the
opportunities that arise demand joint
action
thank you
[Music]
science says that if we harmonize the
whole world we would not be able to
absorb what CO2 is emitted each year the
solution is to leave coal oil and gas
[Music]
we're here marching and saying that we
do not accept mining in our territory we
do not want oil exploitation in the
Amazon that this has already impacted
the lives of our families and our
territories
[Music]